martin take you down memory lane for a
minute
if it's about britney spears i refuse to
answer i'm
serious i swear to god how did you know
that it really was gonna be britney
spears
yes
did you know he's in the toxic music
video i
did a dirty little secret no i didn't
the only thing
i ever saw him in was the ring alex was
like six years old when that
music video came out it was over 15
years ago
yeah she's a lot younger than she looks
that didn't come out well
no no no no
i've painted myself into the corner well
now you have to answer a question about
it
what's the question oh my gosh
martin what do you remember most
about that shoot and working with
britney spears ah i was a little weird
it was a weird day
it was sort of i i think it was a
saturday or sunday i think i got a call
then the few days before like hey can
you do this thing on the weekend
it was actually i've done a movie called
talk for warner brothers and it was a
action motorbike movie and the director
of the movie did all of
brittany's music videos and so they were
doing a cross promotion with mtv
like oh let's get martin in the music
video and then we'll talk about the film
above it
so i was like yeah sure whatever
anything for the movie and but no one
actually mentioned that i actually had
to make out
with britney you know that's not kisser
oh thank you you're a good kisser who's
a better kisser
me or britney spears oh man
it was so long ago i just can't really
recall
the details of that kiss you're just
you're just digging yourself into a hole
with me today i mean i don't know
a lot anyway
britney spears see now you're you're i
got her i got
i'm i'm stuffed either way it was a
lovely day at the office
let's just leave it at that but i'll be
i'll tell you what
the thing that struck me the most after
meeting her was just
how down to earth she was but she was
the sweetest
most genuine she was making fun of
herself
and i just thought that's a cool girl to
be that huge and sort of
be able to make fun of your own stuff i
thought was cool and
i thought she was a sweetheart but oh
not as sweet as you
oh very he just dug himself
right back up playing with that one that
was perfect
set the bar really high alex and you
left
over it martin grey's anatomy
i'm sure you saw the big shocker of
patrick dempsey returning
is there a world in which dr nathan
riggs
ever returns oh gosh
that'd be juicy i'd love to come back as
like the
the guy that was sort of getting in
there on the side when
you know he was out of the way but i
don't
i don't know um what the
writers would have planned for that i
mean
uh i kind of like the way riggs
which is very unusual for character
particularly a male character on that
show to sort of go up
and into the sunset and actually have a
happy ending that was quite nice
um but you know shonda and i stay in
touch i've worked
that was the fourth time i've worked
with her so i would always be open to
anything but right now pretty
pretty happy doing this show i feel like
huh
yeah no i really am i'm having a good
time and
like i said before just it's you know at
the end of the day as an actor you want
you want people to enjoy what you do and
the fact that this has found
such a big audience and people are so
passionate about it
that feels pretty great and i don't know
if i'd want to be
having working all year i'm pretty happy
doing this and having a bit of downtime
too